this sounds like the parrot on a plane
between commercials have saved by the
bell the cure you know where they're
coming in their show in the school from
the outside like the segways yeah when I
well welcome back to the gentleman's
dojo yeah oh yeah to what was that just
feeling good today okay we're feeling
good it's a beautiful day in Southern
California yep yep yep uh to my left
hailing from Detroit Michigan yeah this
city where really nothing exists anymore
but I still love it 162 lean mean pounds
get the [ __ ] out you are definitely
pushing two large exactly over under 200
what do you think I think 202 that's
probably close what are you maybe maybe
around that well yeah i think the lowest
i was recently within the last year jus
was 180 so I could I could drop a few
listen a few listen listen a few how
much do you weigh I i told you i think
around you owe more 90 90 2 i'm pretty
on the mark then it doesn't help having
a cupcake Pete athan Monday night so
that uh that that's got a that's got to
hurt a little bit well my name is steve
byrne i am pittsburgh pennsylvania
usually known as the city of champions
you just got back from aspen correct i
did just get back yeah my we do it all
when you read David yeah you thought
what she did ok always but we all this
some of the things I wrote your else I
always I was like to support you always
like to tell people to come out and see
you be very supportive of you even
though I wasn't there I saw the plane
take was like eight hundred dollars and
I was like now I'm gonna take a loss of
1200 okay mm-hmm that's a cute wave
taken to dig at me okay let's find what
Gary tweets Gary tweet is me while I was
in Aspen yeah find it I got it here we
go attention Aspen looking for some
generic comedy at 8,000 feet then see
Steve Byrne and Gareth Reynold Saturday
and as always no charge oh I took a
picture of me right Aspen and then you
commented
town looks dead should be a great night
for comedy you're my friend right I mean
are you my friend then no and I'm not
working with you this weekend then I
also wrote our company would like to
book you for a party we have a limited
budget would you take a coinstar receipt
as form of payment and you texted me
offline you said get me in touch with
these people haha good god you're
definitely interested you're a horrible
person so today joining us we have great
friend amazing talent beautiful young
lady yup Nasim pedrad uh you may know
her from SNL currently she's on scream
queens she was on Mulaney John Mulaney
sure come that was on Fox for I think 13
episodes we can ask her about all that
but ask her definitely about I mean SNL
SNL just as a comic even when you're
starting off you just that's something
every comic i think entertains the
thought oh sure then you realize how
difficult and obviously from your and
how talented you have to be nicer if i
could you ever on it oh they don't have
a wall up there they don't know you know
they have cast members come out oh they
do and they do the episode I want to
like Michael che came out and did some
stuff with Bobby Moynihan and then the
band plays the whole time and they goof
off and talk to the crowd then they get
into it yeah jb smooth did it for a
little while to member j be smooth yeah
he did it SNL uh yeah i think so i think
he was a cast member for a little bit
later he explained the story about how
he did warm up on it and kind of jump
started him to some other stuff well i
might be the only warm-up guy that
hasn't well I i I've gotten those offers
I just choose to stay where I am right
before I know my strength I know my core
Jesus who's your favorite SNL cast
member wetta II that's a tough one I
gotta to move maybe Chris Farley is up
there yeah well I think you gotta break
it down by season though right I mean
there's so many great seasons with
different cast members because when you
talk to people it depends on with their
generation yeah you know um cuz I go
Murphy obviously I mean you know it's
like yeah i think when i was like i mean
i always love Phil Hartman and Dana
Carvey yeah and then Farley and you know
and if I was a little older I'd probably
say Martin Short and if I was a little
younger I'd say will ferrell but I
up in that nook where Dana Carvey was
just he was in everything yeah he was in
every sketch and any time he appeared
you just like here we go I McDonald ah
yes probably one of the best update
anchors yeah he was great and now your
buddy's doing it so that's got to be a
lot of pressure on Colin your buddies
Colin Jost and there's gotta be a lot of
pressure because obviously no no I'm
being sick right no I'm saying that that
that anchor job is always been a
springboard for other things mean
obviously Seth Meyers is young Tina Fey
I mean to see does he think about that
or does he or she just concerned about
the I'm not him so I I don't know Gary
that's a question you have to ask him
you and I should do improv together cuz
that's a great response no and we're a
team right I should have been like yes
you did you have a peasant comic
everything you would audition for us a
note so no no my focus was real world I
want to get on the real world I wanted
to bang some of the girls in the house
are you serious i did a boy I sure
honestly what was your role what what
was a dream gig for you when you're
starting off as a stand-up what did you
think Oh it'll make you mean getting on
a show any show well what does it show
you wanted to get on probably probably
one of those MTV reality Road rules or
gender equal show where you need no
talent no talent no and you have to be
at least average looking ah well some of
them were better i'm sure you're going
over to that i couldn't get on and i
couldn't drive the Winnebago cuz my eye
condition so how have to tell scary well
he's not driving again what you doing is
jerking off in the back is always so
honestly what was their show or was
there a dream that you had as you're
starting off as a standard did you
really it wasn't doing something wasn't
Sara Night Live I know that there would
you have a goal I star let's see um hmm
I don't [ __ ] your goal guys here we go
good intro to the show do you want a
welcoming uh uh I've never met her
actually oh okay I know first time first
time okay uh welcome to the show miss
Nasim pedrad Nasim thank you so much for
calling in yes the walking hi guys
honesty my left this is Gary Kennan he's
our co-host he does the warm-up
on Conan he does warm up on dr. ken he
did warm up on Sullivan son basically
just trash me the whole time but thank
you so much for credit to two out of
three comedies Gary third one nice to
meet you the worst arm so I you know
everybody knows you from SNL and Mulaney
and scream queens but I gotta ask you as
as someone who had who has a mother that
came over from Korea you obviously came
over from Iran with your parents did
your parents ever put pressure on you or
have they always been supportive of your
pursuit in show business in acting in
being on stage as two people that
immigrated here to the United States do
you ever feel pressure where they always
just on board I mean I honestly can say
they were always super supportive but I
can't even imagine how terrified they
must've been underneath all that like to
immigrate to this country just give up
like so much to give your kids this
better life and then both kids come to
you and they're like I want to pursue
improv how terrified they must have been
but they were really cool about keeping
that to themselves because most they
pressured me was to be like what about
now getting your masters in theater they
were like was it always like Pete but I
didn't want to be an I don't want to be
that kind of student loan debt so I I
said no um and they were like all right
well I gotta ask you what what are the
under because I think before we had we
talked just personally but what there's
some pretty heavy circumstances under
which they moved here right yeah I was a
it was crazy I mean they met here they
were studying abroad my dad was at UC
Berkeley they were kind of just planning
on going to college in the States and
then moving back to Iran and then the
revolution there happened in 79 so in 81
they went back to like sell their house
and like patent get rid of everything
and come back out here and my mom had me
during that in 81 and it was a little
post-revolution Iran
it was also like in the middle of the
iran-iraq war the Dacians like in labor
with me all her siblings were like it
was chaos everyone was like you know
there's a lot going on um and people
were like in prison it was just a very
tumultuous crazy time but they were able
to sort of wrap their lives up there and
then my dad came to the state's my mom
when I couldn't come right away we had
to go like Germany for a year well and
then we ended up I met my dad at LAX and
I was three I think Wow and out of all
that heartache and duress as you
mentioned do your parents ever you know
do they ever talk about the fact that
wow you not only you but also your your
sister your younger sister are involved
in comedy so it has it been in some form
or some way cathartic for them to see
you know look what we moved out of and
now look at what our daughters are out
there on the airwaves and on our
television sets providing comedy for
everybody yeah for sure I mean there's
so much milder by it still I think but
they love it I mean my dad especially
like once I started doing SML because
they're immigrants so they don't like I
grew up a lot of times feeling like you
know it was harder to I didn't have like
all the pop culture references that my
friends had my parents just didn't grow
up here so i was really like insecure
about that as a kid just wanting this
it's like a group in concert and I'm
like you're ruining my life because if
you don't know about like these very
American things but you know because
there's a kid you just want to fit in
but now I'm old enough to just
appreciate how hilarious they are and
they're in their foreignness but um but
yeah like they when I got to know
watching a show every Saturday that was
like covering every bit topical copes
related and and relevant
so to have my like middle-aged Iranian
father go from having no awareness of
that stuff to having i would say too
much awareness like so the point where
at some point like I I remember I was
just like shopping one day he called me
he's like hey guess what today is it's
adam levine's birthday would they come
to the tapings would they come see you
live when you did it knew they came at
least once or twice a year yeah they
live in California so they would fly out
every season it was at a big thing for
them to see me because that's you know
chaos there with all the gas bands and
stuff like that supposed to be a very
cool thing to see I'm een Steve did
Sullivan & Son for three years and his
parents never once came which you shot
the [ __ ] so that's pretty good very true
and you're the washed human being I've
ever met mullet they were not proud of
you fuzz oh my proud of her yeah I'm not
proud of yeah they were on product yeah
they a timeshare in Europe for their six
months we'll talk so it may seem so so
you move here you're doing great and
then you go to UCLA if there are you is
that when you're you know you study
theatre is that when you started getting
involved in comedy we're thinking of
improv and sketch yeah I mean in high
school I did everything you know that is
offered to at the high school level
which is just like an improv team and
drama club and doing like the comedies
and you know like within the theater
program but then I I was like well I'm
not Asian for the theater program at
UCLA if for some reason I bent in and
try to at least ride that out and see
see if I could even like humor the
possibility of having a career or
attempting to have a career in it so at
UCLA that's kind of where and I was
doing like dramatic stuff an act acting
program as well but that's when I
started to kind of write more when I was
writing comedy and I started taking
classes at The Groundlings and what I
loved about doing that and writing was
that it was just like especially you see
I mean I went to school with so many
great actors and actresses and even
after I graduated I just started to feel
really terrified at the notion of just
like having my entire career be hinged
on the possibility of an audition that
I'm then going up against a million
other girls for you know so writing was
a way of me like having a little bit of
control mizzium can you explain to Gary
what writing is next so yeah it started
writing comedy so that I could then
perform it and not be waiting around for
like you know these opportunities to
come by um because but where did I put
myself that part lays into then next
thing was gonna ask you is that you
wrote your own one-woman show me myself
and I ran was that the first kind of
tent pole for you that kind of jump
started things would you say that was my
big yeah yeah that was the that's one of
the biggest like shift in my career took
place because up until then I had been
doing you know you see being Groundlings
that were great and in between you know
some of those in between the levels
there sometimes you have to like wait a
year because there's like a wait list to
get to the next level and during that
time I was just like in an effort to not
lose my mind I was like I have to keep
performing I have to just keep
performing so I am I wrote that one
woman show as a submission to the it was
like the year after F Aspen Comedy
Festival anyway so it was like the HBO
Connie festival in vegas and they you
know they take submissions in different
categories and one of the categories was
like a 30 minute one-person show so i
used that as sort of a deadline for
myself and I wrote just I wrote you know
that show submitted it it got in once i
went there that's kind of what gave me
the exposure i was hoping for i got an
agent out of that and then that agent
I'm still with to this day and he was
like from that
so he was like we got to get you seen so
I think he he told Tina Fey about my
show she saw it and then recommended me
to Lorne Michaels fur I don't know and
that's when the process began of getting
my first of two auditions and it will
out to the ground my salami and then
yeah could you explain to Steve what an
agent is okay chalk one up for the good
guy we just moved here from Wichita so
let me see I gotta ask you what is it
what is it like getting do you remember
the exact moment where you were what you
were doing when you got the call that
you got SNL oh that I actually got it
yeah I was well I had this auditioned
for the second time so by then I was
just like whatever happens happens a lot
of times a lot of people audition two or
three times and this year it happened to
be in the same summer so I did my first
audition and I was like okay well if
they have an audition again it won't be
till next summer then they were like
actually you're coming back in two weeks
and we want all new material so I did
that and then I like landed in LA from
that and they were like you're turning
right back around you're gonna go meet
with Lauren oh um and you have this like
one-on-one meeting where I think the
point of it is just for him to kind of
make sure you're not crazy and he didn't
tell me I didn't know still that I had
gotten it he knew but he didn't say in
the meeting and then I left and I was
like wandering around midtown my phone
died so i went into like a cingular
wireless store to charge it was like
fully just trolling at the cingular
wireless door like sitting on the floor
waiting for my phone to turn on and then
when i turned on i got like a million
phone calls and voicemails and then um
yeah how crazy is it that you're you're
celebrating with the staff of the
cingular wireless while your phone is
plugged in be on the front desk it's a
guys you'll never believe this what what
do you what did you do for your your two
auditions like what were the
eat what were the audition well what did
you do I mean all they tell you is you
have five minutes so everybody that
audition is different um I have never
actually went I've never gone back and
looked at mine they're on the server in
the offices of SNL I'd be way too
mortified but it was for me I was like
my best bet is going to be like just
showing you know some versatility so I
did like characters from I did like a
few celebrity impressions and then just
character from The Groundlings that i
had developed and then I kind of like I
was told we would only be auditioning
once per summer you know so kind of blew
my wad on the first audition why they
called back and they're like you need
all new material I was like [ __ ] what am
I gonna do sure um so I was like
literally like googling actress on the
slightest writing part of my audition
it's like on the flight over and in the
hotel room but I ended up doing like not
as main street i did--like i remember i
did like my second audition I do like
charlyne yi oh wow girl from knocked up
yeah and like Dora the Explorer real
life well I got to say my favorite
impression I hope you don't mind we're
gonna just play a brief clip and then
I'll ask you this about this real quick
and they were going to wrap this up
because I know you got to do something
but it's gonna place really quick
this one I don't like this one so this
seemed Aziz Ansari that impression I
remember the first time sitting on my
couch watching that just dying I mean
you nailed that impression and I got oh
my god did he was he cool with it or
what's because I know he'd come to those
after parties and stuff with and is that
something to where you do an impression
and you meet the person afterwards is
there over static oh yeah its you its
first of all like I tried so hard
getting that they kept cutting they cut
that a dress rehearsal I don't know if
it's because I was so jarringly
resembled him it was but everyone was
like this we don't know what to do with
this that's why I ended up like showing
a clip of it on Conan then we release it
on Funny or Die later but I thought that
that's like perfect example of like you
do so much stuff that doesn't even like
you know make it to the actual show that
everyone's watching Roy that one got cut
at dress but he I I ran into any one
year at the white house correspondents
dinner right after I'd film that I was
like Aziz look it disease a picture and
he was so cool about it but I could tell
mortified I really look like him
incredible well right for the first time
I'm like I would actually sleep with
Aziz now this seemed we gotta ask you to
wrap this up because I know you got to
do something we're gonna see how good
Wikipedia knows Nasim pedrad so here's
the first question I want to ask you
according to wikipedia what is your
first television role ah er wrong
Gilmore I'm wrong I'm a bad memory Oh
with gilmore girls before year yeah blur
okay that was maybe I'm wrong on that
you are definitely you could be right
but you could be wrong mornin Harve
guess you never know mom mailed this
game do you don't have that much
background would you shut the [ __ ] sorry
here's our second question of three what
is your first film role according to
wikipedia
I'll give you a head it sounds like
something animated it sounds like
something you'd see on Cinemax oh my god
I'm really eating it I don't remember um
so probably sounds like Cinemax probably
not despicable me it would be cool cool
73 virgins oh my god that is considered
a movie that happened awesome this is
the last question that is a deep cut
yeah um hit the mark as best as you can
according to wikipedia how many
impressions did you do on SNL I have the
number you let me know what you think
the number would be i literally have no
idea um it's the number 25 whoa pretty
close a little over 28 28 impressions
according to wikipedia and what's the
impression you get at but this isn't on
Wikipedia but what is what is the
impression you get asked to do most when
somebody runs into you hey do this one
usually it's usually split between
Arianna Huffington and Kim Kardashian
okay well this eerie two very different
people we we know you got it we know you
got a tight schedule we cannot thank you
enough for spending time with us you're
literally one of my favorite human
beings in the world I love you and
continued success you about you thank
you so much I hope you guys work out all
your issues we won't all right Nasim
pedrad everybody thank you so much the
same we love you bye guys all right fire
that was awesome and by the way I could
have asked her a thousand more questions
but you know we do have a time crunch
and uh does she do a lot of stand-up at
The Comedy Store she does not do
stand-up she's not sketch improv and
just one of the best and I did want to
ask her about the transition from
leaving SNL to go to Mulaney and then I
think any time you take that gamble it's
like well the show you know and look at
the time Mulaney was like gonna be the
hitch is gonna be the hit show signs
and so I think you're thinking wow this
is a given Lawrence producing it it's on
fox they're really getting behind it and
you know it lasted 13 episodes yeah
shame because I I watched the first few
episodes I really did I thought I
thought the show was really funny i
really enjoyed the heck out of it and
i'm a big fan of John mulaney's as a
stand-up as well too so I know that uh
he's got a new special out now the
comeback kid which is awesome that is on
netflix I gotta say this after spending
the weekend I went to Netflix and
watched a bunch of different stand-up
specials to just see the intros watched
some of them I saw Thomas agura's
special mostly stories I don't know if
you've seen this he's cold open is
literally one of the funniest cold
millions I've seen and I just worked
with Gareth Reynolds and a spy go dude
you got to see this so we played it and
Gareth watched it the next morning again
uh he any we go to breakfast he's like
do it i just watched that it's [ __ ]
funny so if you get a chance well he's
check it out oh and up i mean i know
that he did a couple of shows locally
here in Burbank at a club and I think a
lot of them were sold out I mean he
really has a great little following he
goes on the road and there's something I
said open for him and say he's just a
good dude and he just had a baby with
his wife ooh yeah they have a very
popular podcast right now as well and
we've got to mention that our good
friend Ari Shaffir is returning yeah to
Comedy Central with I think this is the
second season is it the second season
for third third season of this is not
happening where he gets a bunch of great
comics to tell some really embarrassing
story al Madrigal is gonna be on Al's on
this season our great friend Steve
Simone from good times that podcast he's
on this season so definitely check that
out Tuesday nights I think it's a ten
o'clock is that right 1230 am sorry 1230
a.m. tuesday so technically wednesday i
guess but set the DVR if you're going to
be asleep but ari's great guy uh great
podcast you it's about that time you
want to let the folks know uh I was
gonna ask you what what TV show you got
coming up anything I just want to know
what's on my TV show this was such a fun
yet no no I'm just
I guess I'm right what's your good since
Mulaney got canceled maybe TBS will pick
it up alrighty here we go let's see you
are the [ __ ] um what is it go oh this is
great by the way you and I travel a lot
right we talked about our hotel scams by
the way my mom used one of the little
tidbits that we gave out last door yeah
yeah she got a free adult video in the
room he was able to work hardest um
disgusting go on what is the deal we are
giving away oh this gonna be great for
all of our travelers out there Airbnb
has just a team with us they love our
show we just got a call from corporate
up in Mountain View California which is
where they're located and to find folks
of Airbnb they said to ask you stay in
condos a lot they said hey we want to
give away a little gift certificate for
people on shore i was going to post so
let's do a three hundred fifty dollars
boom the fine folks of Airbnb now Chico
350 that you know you could stay a month
in Omaha or one night in New York City
it's up to you how you choose to use the
air B&B coupon but we'll do the 19th
caller with the phrase that pays wow I
love it for Airbnb was great oh you
label yeah well we'd like to thank Nasim
God effect Nasim scream queens scream
queens on Fox she's I think she's
working on so I don't know if I could
measure but but anyways that girls she's
been working nonstop for years so uh be
on the lookout for her you can follow
her on twitter i believe sure where they
follow you on you
did you pump up the music just so
wouldn't hear me know where we find a
comedy you know that
I know it at Kenan comedy at steve byrne
live guys we do want to talk to you
about your job so hit us up on twitter
at cannon comedy at steve byrne live we
want to talk to you about your
occupation we're still gonna do our
thing with our comedians are friends
that we love yes what we do want to make
that a part of the show as well you have
kind of a crazy goofy gig if you want to
talk about it what not we would love to
absolutely discuss it with you and you
can remain anonymous which exactly be
what we call Steve's career anonymous
action is made